c-span 2.
[Music]
this is c-span's america and the courts
next oral argument from the landmark
abortion case roe versus wade this case
was argued before the supreme court on
december 13th 1971
at the time under texas law having or
performing an abortion was illegal
unless to save the life of the mother
sarah weddington argued for roe the
texas woman who sought an abortion texas
assistant attorney general jay floyd
represented the government
we'll hear arguments in number 18
against uh
we
redington you may proceed whenever
you're ready
[Applause]
mr chief justice and may it please the
court
the instant case is a direct appeal from
a decision of united states district
court for the northern district of texas
the court declared the texas abortion
law to be unconstitutional for two
reasons
first that the law was impermissibly
vague and second
that it violated a woman's right to
determine to continue or terminate a
pregnancy
although the court granted declaratory
relief the court denied oppellant's
request for injunctive release
the texas law in question permits
abortions to be performed only in
instances where is for the purpose of
saving the life of the woman
the case originated with the filing of
two separate complaints the first being
filed on behalf of jane roe an unmarried
pregnant girl and the second being filed
on behalf of jane and mary doe a married
couple
jane roe the pregnant woman had gone to
several dallas positions seeking an
abortion but had been refused care
because of the texas law
she filed suit on behalf of herself and
all those women
who have in the past at that present
time or in the future would seek
termination of a pregnancy
in her affidavit she did state some of
the reasons that she desired an abortion
at the time she sought one
but contrary to the contentions of
abhili she continued to desire the
abortion and it was not only at the time
she sought the abortion that her desire
was to terminate the pregnancy
when this case was in the
district court uh
the
[Music]
case of brewich against the united
states have not been decided here
correct
now that's uh do you think that has
disposed of some of the questions raised
now
your honor i do not in the voyage
decision this court was working with a
statute which provided that an abortion
could be performed for reasons of health
or life
our texas statute provides an abortion
only where it is where it is for the
purpose of saving the life of the woman
since the voyage decision was rendered
the texas court of criminal appeals
which is our highest court of criminal
jurisdiction
has held that the texas law is not vague
citing the voyage decision but saying
that the texas law is more definite than
the dc law so obviously the court of
criminal appeals doesn't feel that the
two are the same
and in the
decision the justices of this court
emphasized continuously
that
a doctor as a matter of routine works
with the problem of what is best for the
health of his patients
we submit that a doctor is not used to
being restricted to acting only when
it's for the purpose of saving the life
of the woman
and that health is a continuum which
runs into life and a doctor in our state
does not know whether he can
perform an abortion only when when death
is imminent or when the woman's life
would be shortened
he does not know if
the death must be certain or if it could
be
an increase in probability of her death
so here in the district doctors are able
to exercise their normal matter of
judgment whether or not the health of a
woman mental or physical would be
affected
but in texas we tell a doctor that
unless he can decide whether it's
necessary for the purpose of saving her
life and for no other reason
that he is subject to criminal sanctions
i think it's important to note the range
of problems that could be presented to a
doctor the court for example uh cited
the instance of suicide if a woman comes
in alleging that she will commit suicide
is it then necessary for him to do or
can he do an abortion for the purpose of
saving her life
or is that a situation where he has to
have something more i think all of those
questions cannot be answered at this
point
this brings up the married couple in our
case the woman in that case had a
neurochemical condition her doctor had
advised her not to get pregnant and not
to take the birth control pill
she was using alternative means of birth
control but she and her husband were
fearful that she would become pregnant
and that although the neurochemical
condition would impair her health
there was
evidently her doctor did not feel that
she would die if she continued the
pregnancy
and certainly they were very concerned
about the effects of the statute and her
physician seemed uncertain about its
implication
the doctors in our state
continue
to feel that our law is vague
certainly we introduced affidavits in
the lower court to that effect
since the time of the lower court ruling
the district attorney in texas
has said that he will that he considers
the
federal court decision there not to be
binding and he is
uh and we do have a letter from him and
the first thing in our uh appendix to
the brief stating that he will continue
to prosecute
so the doctors in texas even with the
federal decision and even after the
voice decision do not feel free to
perform abortions and instead 728 women
in the first nine months after the
decision went to new york for an
abortion
texas women are coming here
it's
so often the poor and the disadvantaged
in texas who were not able to escape the
effect of the law
certainly there are many texas women who
are affected because our doctors
still feel uncertain about the impact
of the law even in light of the fluid's
decision
[Applause]
well then of course
mrs weddington you make
many additional constitutional attacks
upon the
texas statute and only one was
and the court explicitly didn't read any
of the other claims and you make many
other claims
and of course before you get to any of
those there's many threshold
[Applause]
of course important to point out to the
court that
in my reading of younger versus harris
and
the the companion cases
all the court was concerned about in
those cases was a situation where there
was an attempt
to interfere with the pending state
criminal prosecution
in this case as i pointed out the
original parties to this uh matter are
women and in one case the husband
the women certainly are not subject to
prosecution in the state of texas they
are it is impossible for them to stand
in the criminal dock and litigate their
interests
they came seeking injunctive relief but
it was not against pending state
criminal prosecution they were not even
aware of the prosecution against dr
halford today could they undertake this
law be
charged as uh accomplices no you're
conspirators
no we have expressed texas cases in one
situation woodrow versus state and 1880
case the woman had taken a potion to
induce abortion and the texas court
specifically said that the woman is
guilty of no crime even in that
situation and that in fact she is the
victim of our law
she can't there is no declaratory relief
available for these plaintiffs their
only forum was the federal court and it
was to those courts that they turn your
three plaintiffs here in representing
classes like that there were yes
one an unmarried pregnant woman yeah
a
married couple yes
[Music]
and the shown that it would be injurious
to the wife's health to have a child and
also injurious to her health to use the
most efficient form of
birth control
and then third is a physician
who is under indictment or what at the
the physician intervened after the order
was entered granting jane roe a
three-judge court and he intervened
again asking only
that future prosecution under the law
being joined he did not ask any relief
of the court relating to his pending
state criminal prosecution
he did specifically in his complaint
reserve the right to ask for future
relief but that was never done
and certainly in the future if he were
to ask for release the court would have
the
guidance of the younger versus harris
companion cases
but there was in no way any request
for any
action to interfere with the pending
criminal prosecutions then in process
as to
there is
an allegation that the question is moved
since the woman has now had
has carried the pregnancy to term
and i think
it is impo it is important to realize
that
there are several important aspects in
which this case differs from the case
that the courts might usually be
presented
first the case is different in the
nature of the interest which is involved
and in the extent to which personal
determination is undermined by this
statute the effect that it has on women
second it is unique in the type of
injury that's presented
certainly there are some injuries that
can be compensated and
most last over a sufficient period of
time for the courts to litigate the
interest
but in this case a progressing pregnancy
does not suspend itself in order to give
the time
uh the courts time to act
certainly jane rowe brought her suit as
soon as she knew she was pregnant as
soon as she had sought an abortion and
been denied
she came to federal court she came on
behalf of a class of women and i don't
think there's any questions that women
in texas continue to desire abortions
and to speak them out outside our state
there was an absence of any other uh
remedy and
without the ability to litigate her
claim
as a pregnant woman who came seeking
relief and who's
whom was affected by the time required
for the federal process not not because
of any infirmity in her own
attempts to litigate her interests that
this will in fact be a case
certainly presenting substantial federal
question and yet evading review in the
future
i think uh the third way in which it is
unique is as i've stated the fact that
it is the only forum available to these
women
they have no other way to litigate their
interest does that mean that there is no
possibility of getting a declaratory
judgment under texas law yes your honor
declaratory judgments in the state of
texas are limited to a situation where
property rights are involved and we also
have a very unusual situation in texas
where we have two concurrent
jurisdictions one the civil and one the
criminal
and it even there are some cases which
indicate that our state supreme court
would not have the ability to mandamus
any of the criminal prosecution officers
because the texas court of criminal
appeals has jurisdiction as to all
criminal matters in the state of texas
so even if the woman had been able to
bring a declaratory judgment which she
couldn't
she couldn't have gotten any sort of
relief against future prosecution
and it was exactly the absence of the
court granting
an injunction against future
prosecutions which have resulted in the
irreparable injuries these women have
suffered
in texas the woman is the victim
the state cannot deny the effects that
this law has on the women of texas
certainly there are problems regarding
even the use of contraception uh
abortion now for a woman is safer than
childbirth
in the absence of abortion or legal
medically safe abortions women often
result to the illegal abortion which
certainly carry risks of death all the
side effects such as severe infection
permanent sterility all the
complications that result
and in fact if the woman is unable to
get either a legal abortion or an
illegal abortion in our state she can do
a self-abortion which is certainly
perhaps by far the most dangerous and
that is no crime
she
is in our state
[Applause]
oh
the microphone won't uh be effective
thank you
uh
texas for example does it appears to us
would not allow any relief at all even
in situations where the mother uh would
suffer perhaps serious physical or
mental harm there's certainly a great
question about it
if the pregnancy would result in the
birth of a deformed or defective child
she has no relief
regardless of the circumstances of
conception whether it was because of
rape incest whether she is extremely
immature she has no relief
i think it's without question that
pregnancy to a woman can completely
disrupt her life
whether she's unmarried whether she's
pursuing an education whether she's
pursuing a career whether she has family
problems
all of the problems
of
personal and family life for a woman are
bound up in the problem of abortion
for example in our state there are many
schools where a woman is forced to quit
if she becomes pregnant in the city of
austin that is true a woman if she
becomes pregnant and is in high school
must resign or must drop out of regular
educa regular education process and
that's true of some uh
colleges in our state
in the matter of uh employment she often
is forced to quit at an early point in
her pregnancy she has no
provision for maternity leave she has
she uh cannot get unemployment
compensation under our laws because the
law holds that she is not eligible for
employment being pregnant and therefore
is eligible for no unemployment
compensation at the same time she can
get no welfare to help her at a time
when she has no unemployment
compensation and she's not eligible for
any help in getting a job to provide for
herself
there is no duty for employers to rehire
women if they must drop out to carry a
pregnancy to term
and of course this is especially hard on
the many women in texas who are heads of
their own household and must provide for
their already existing children
and obviously
the responsibility of raising a child is
the most serious one and the time
and emotional investment that must be
made cannot be denied
so a pregnancy to a woman is perhaps one
of the most determinative
aspects of her life
it disrupts her
her body it disrupts her education it
disrupts her employment and it often
disrupts her entire family life
and we feel that because of the impact
on the woman
this certainly
and as far as there are any rights which
are fundamental is a matter which is of
such fundamental and basic concern to
the woman involved
that she should be allowed to make the
choice as to whether to continue or to
terminate her pregnancy
i think the question is equally serious
for the physicians of our state
they are seeking to practice medicine
in what they consider the highest method
of practice
we have affidavits in the back of our
brief from each of the heads of public
of heads of obstetrics and gynecology
departments from each of our public
medical schools in texas
and each of them
points out that they were willing and
interested
to immediately begin to formulate
methods of providing care and services
for women who are pregnant and who do
not desire to continue the pregnancy
they were stopped cold in their efforts
even with the declaratory judgment
because of the da's position that they
would continue to prosecute
[Applause]
so far on the merits you
told us about the
important impact of this law and it's
made a very eloquent policy argument
against it
i trust you are going to get to what
provisions of the constitution you rely
on because of course we're
very
your honor
in the lower court as i'm sure you're
aware the court held that the right to
determine whether or not to continue a
pregnancy rested upon the ninth
amendment
which of course reserves those rights
not specifically enumerated to the
government to the people
i think it is important to note uh in a
law review article recently submitted to
the court and uh
distributed among council by professor
cyril means junior
entitled the phoenix of abortional uh
freedom
that at the time the constitution was
adopted there was no common law
prohibition against abortion that they
were available to the women of this
country
certainly under the griswold decision it
appears that
the members of the court
in that case were obviously divided as
to the specific
constitutional framework of the right
which they held to exist in the griswold
decision
i'm a little reluctant to uh
aspire to a wisdom that the court did
not was not in agreement on
i do feel that it is that the ninth
amendment is an appropriate place for
the freedom to rest i think the 14th
amendment is equally an appropriate
place under the rights of persons to
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness i think in as far as liberty
is meaningful that liberty to these
women would mean
liberty from
being forced to continue the unwanted
pregnancy
you're relying in this
branch of your argument simply on the
due process clause of the 14th amendment
we had originally brought the suit
alleging both the due process clause the
equal protection clause the ninth
amendment
and a variety of others
yeah right
since the district court found the right
to reside in the ninth amendment
we pointed our attention in the brief to
that particular aspect of the
constitution
but i think we would not presume
i
i do feel that that in so much as
members of the court had said that the
ninth amendment applies to rights
reserved to the people and those which
were most important and certainly this
is that the ninth amendment is the
appropriate place in so far as the court
has said that uh
that life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness involved the very most
fundamental thing of people
that
this matter is one of those most
fundamental matters
i think in as far as the court has said
that there is a penumbra that exists
to encompass the entire uh purpose of
the constitution
that i think one of the purposes of the
constitution was to guarantee to the
individual the right to determine the
course of their own lives insofar as
there was perhaps no compelling state
interest and we allege there is none in
this case
but there again
uh the right fits within the framework
of the previous decisions of this course
what is the asserted
state interest
does the is there any legislative
history
about this statute no sir your honor
no sir there is not
the only
legislative history of course is that
which is found in other states which has
been pointed out to the court before and
professor means points out again that
these statutes
were adopted for the health of the
mother certainly the texas courts have
referred to the woman as being the
victim and they have never referred to
anyone else as being the victim
uh
times have have certainly changed i
think it's important to to realize that
in texas self-abortion is no crime the
woman is guilty of no crime even though
she seeks out the doctor even though she
can sense even though she participates
even though she pays for the procedure
she again is guilty as no crime
whatsoever
it's also interesting that our statute
uh
the penalty for the offense of abortion
depends on whether or not the consent of
the woman was obtained prior to the
procedure it's double if you don't get
her consent
uh
there is uh
no indication in fondren versus state
for example the court ruled that a woman
who commits an abortion on herself is
guilty of no crime again she being
regarded as the victim rather than the
perpetrator of the crime
obviously in our state the offense is
not murder it is an abortion which
carries a significantly lesser offense
there is no requirement of
even though the state in its breed
points out the development of the fetus
at an eight-week period the same state
does not require any death certificate
or any formalities of birth that the
products of such a conception would be
handled merely as a pathological
specimen and the statute doesn't make
any distinctions
uh based upon what uh period of
pregnancy and the abortion is performing
know your honor
there is no time limit or indication of
time whatsoever
so i think well do you make any
difference
no sir i i do
i feel that the question of a time limit
is not strictly before the court because
of the nature of the situation in which
the case is uh handled
certainly i think it's a practical
matter though most of the states that do
have some time limit indicated still
permit abortions beyond the time limit
for specified reasons usually again
where the health of the mother is what's
your constitutional position
as to a time limit what about whatever
cause the constitution you rest on the
night and then the due process uh
the general pattern the numbers
it is
it is our position that
the freedom involved is that of a woman
to determine whether or not to continue
a pregnancy obviously i have a much more
difficult time
uh saying that the state has no interest
in late pregnancy
i think it's more the emotional response
to a late pregnancy rather than it is
any uh
constitutional
um
i guess by persons considering the issue
outside the legal context i think as far
as the state
do you or don't you say that the
constitutional uh i would say that you
the constitution as i read it and is
interpreted and documented by professor
means attaches protection to the person
at the time of birth those persons born
our citizens
the enumeration clause we count those
people who are born the constitution as
i see it gives protections to people
after birth
the issue here i guess
[Applause]
on your appeal is whether you were
entitled to injunctivally yes sir
assuming that
in all other respects
your arguments were accepted
why do you think in addition to
declaratory release or entitlement
those are different things yes sir uh
certainly
in your descent you point out in perez
versus ledezma concurring visiting
that there are different standards which
apply to the declaratory judgment and to
injunctive relief
yes that's correct
uh and that's what the court said
following zwickler versus cuda that even
though they were grinding declaratory uh
declaratory relief it's different
considerations applied estrogen junctive
relief
but it seems that the opinions of this
court have established that where there
is a reference there is great and
immediate threat of irreparable injury
with no adequate remedy and state court
that an injunction is still proper
and it is our position that there is
great and immediate threat of
irreparable injuries
in the form of a continuing pregnancy
that will not abate and that continues
so you're you're really
you're you're asserting that the the
pregnant woman has standing yeah in this
case
and the
married couple uh where the wife is not
pregnant understanding yes
what about the doctor of where
a criminal constitution was already
pending against it
the doctor as i said was asking no
relief as to the pending prosecution he
was only asking relief as to future
prosecution
yes your honor he joined in both the
request for the declaratory judgment
younger against uh younger and the
companion patients cover
judgment
where where they were pending uh where
the
samuel versus michael as i read it did
say
that where you have an a request for
declaratory judgment there would be an
effect on a pending criminal prosecution
there was one pending when this action
was brought that one about those against
dr halford however in this case
we submit that if there is to be any
meaning
to the federal courts as the supreme
arbiters of constitutional rights
that they must be able to act at least
in some form when there are pending
criminal prosecutions not particularly
against the person involved in the
prosecution but others have said that
federal courts may but that's what
limited the situations for those of you
where the prostitution
uh improperly is used as a device to
harass
another person prosecuting foreign yes
your honor but again
as i understood it
i'm suggesting that in this case
these the women in particular brought a
declaratory action having nothing to do
with the pending state criminal
prosecution
and that the intervention of the doctor
certainly should not be sufficient
right
that the the intervention that because
the doctor intervened
when he was asking no request no relief
as to the pending state criminal
prosecution
that his intervention and he was asking
nothing he was asking what no he wasn't
against the continuance of that process
that's correct he is willing to litigate
his
judgment as to future prosecution except
that
and what your defense said was incorrect
it wasn't that okay
i think perhaps
we would stress that there are two
separate actions before the court first
out of the women and second that of the
doctor so that even though even though
the doctor even though the court might
find that the doctor was an
inappropriate party for relief it
certainly would not affect the original
action as brought by the women all right
i come back again if we're left only
with the ladies action
uh
you're suggesting that
the uh
claritary relief they already obtained
is not enough because that doesn't help
terminate the statement
because they are still
uh subject to the irreparable injury and
have no adequate state remedy and if if
they are not able to continue to
litigate their interest in this
situation anytime there was any
prosecution pending against anyone in
the state at any point in the appeal for
example the thompson case was filed in
1968 it's been decided now in our state
courts it's on appeal or it will be
appealed here i think and certainly if
they cannot litigate their interests
while there's prosecution pending
against the doctor they will
in many instances where a statute where
they're supposed to answer
[Applause]
prosecution against the doctor there's
not going to be any doctor that's going
to
be available
yes they cannot
even
decide to take the risk for themselves
under the declaratory judgment they must
rely on another person to take that risk
but certainly the doctor raised not only
his own rights but the rights of his
patients and those same patients are
suffering the same sort of irreparable
injury that the original plaintiff were
suffering
couldn't the doctor raise that same
point in the criminal prosecution
yes your honor he can but i i don't feel
it's appropriate
to
make those women who are most vitally
affected certainly more so than the
doctor who can merely decide not to
perform an abortion and thereby escape
talking about the doctor you said there
were two separate issues here
and the issue involved in the doctor is
to mitigate everything he's now
litigating him
yes your honor my point being that that
these women should not
be
compelled to leave it up to a doctor to
litigate those things oh well he's going
to obviously defend himself in a
criminal prosecution he didn't count on
him to do that
well i think there are different
interests involved and and in most
criminal prosecutions the doctors would
bring up other
uh problems such as i couldn't do it or
something yeah or the witnesses have
disappeared or it really was for this
reason in this particular case but uh
has has this defense ever been
interposed in a
texas criminal case yes
there is one recent opinion thompson
versus the state of texas which the
attorney general attempted to bring to
the attention of the court and it was
not printed and the court rejected it
but it was a decision about a month and
a half ago which originated in houston a
doctor there was
uh
indicted on a charge of abortion at
trial he used only an alibi defense but
on his appeal he did raise the same
constitutional questions that we raised
in the federal court
no that was too late no your honor they
they could have but they didn't they
went ahead and litigated those issues
and our texas board of criminal appeals
which is our highest court
uh has now held that the statute is not
the exciting voyage which again i would
contend as an incorrect reliance that's
the case you decided to the chief
justice yeah
and second that they're that they
specifically did not determine whether
or not there was a right to privacy but
did hold there was a compelling interest
so in that particular situation which is
the only situation a doctor did attempt
to litigate the senator's card of
criminal appeals has basically upheld
the constitution now
they have held really direct directly in
opposition to the federal court opinion
from which we are appealing
they have filed a motion for re-hearing
in the state court of criminal appeals
which will be argued tomorrow
i think it's very unlikely
that the court would
change its opinion and it is the
intention of those parties to appeal
how does texas law in other areas of the
law
uh give rights to unborn children in the
areas of trust and estates and wills
know your honor only only if they are
born alive we have the supreme court of
texas recently has held in one case that
there is an action for prenatal injuries
at any stage prior to birth but only
upon the condition that it be born alive
the same is true of our property law the
child must be born alive and i i think
there is a distinction between those
children which are ultimately born and i
think it is appropriate to give them
retroactive rights but i think that's a
completely different question from
whether or not they had rights at the
time they were still in the world what
about the uh
unborn child who is uh
as a result of an accident killed or
whatever the word you want to use for
there has been no situation litigated
like that in texas but suppose you noted
that the other got around the country uh
the iowa supreme court about uh two
weeks ago held that where it was still
born there was no uh
uh cause of action whatsoever the
children the mother
for the mother well now oh i'm speaking
excuse me solely for the fetus that the
fetus had no independent right that the
mother the mother
recovering for the death of the child or
for the whatever you want only for her
injury only for her does that include
anything with regard to the title
no john
[Applause]
thank you thank you uh mrs weddington mr
floyd
mr chief justice i please support
it's an old joke but when i argue man
argus against two beautiful ladies like
this they're going to have the last word
i before i proceed to the original issue
in this case which was the propriety
of the trial court
uh grant or denying injunctive relief
i would like to bring the court's
attention
some grave matters concerning
what has been referred to as the
standing of the parties
uh the
couple involved
they were a married properly childless
married couple
the only
matter
evidence or whatever in the record
concerning
their contentions
is contained in their first amended
original petition
that is
that
the woman
would have difficulty
if she became pregnant in carrying a
child to childbirth
further that they were unprepared for
parenthood
we submit to the court
that their cause of action is strictly
based upon conjecture conjecture
will they continue the marriage
will her health improve
uh
will
the they then be at some time in the
future prepared or unpaired prepared for
for parenthood
[Applause]
there is no fear of prosecution by mary
dome
if we accept all contentions
of these this married couple
uh
we submit that they still do not come
under the prescribed conditions of glass
versus coin
and golden versus zwickler
we feel that the lower court property
denied them standing
as to the unmarried
pregnant female
uh a unique situation arises in
[Applause]
is her action now moot
of course if mood there is no case or
controversy class action i think it was
a class action
surely you would
i suppose we could almost take judicial
notice of the fact that there
are at any given time
unmarried pregnant females in the state
of texas
yes sir
i would say that the only thing that
could uphold her
uh or her standing would be or or
eliminate the lucius issue would be
whether or not this is a class action on
her part
yes right
the record that came up to this court
contains
the
amended petition of jane rowe
an unsigned
alias affidavit
and that is all
she alleges that she was pregnant on
april the 20th 1970 which is some 21
months ago
now i think that it is
it has been recognized by
the apollo's council that she is no
longer pregnant
this court has consistently held that
the time of determination of mootness is
when the hearing is before the court
that is a case can become moved from the
hearing the trial for it until the time
it reaches this court
we do not feel a felon's authority
contained in their brief
will substantiate
their her contention
that the case is not moved
uh the
i might add this that i i believe the
law to be that
if there is a reasonable possibility of
reoccurrence
of the situation then the case would not
be moved now this is the wt grant case
the other case are cases concern orders
of the interstate commerce commission
which the court holds that there is a
possibility or a reasonable possibility
of continuation of those orders and the
the capability of repetition it deals
mainly with the capability of repetition
we think the
case of jane rowe can be easily compared
to hall versus beals
in that particular case a group of
voters
instituted a class action
complaining of a colorado statute
which prescribed a residency requirement
of six months
they had at the time
lived in the states
or at the time of the election were
lived in the state some four or five
months
the case came up through the lower
courts of this court and in the meantime
colorado repealed the statute
and established a two months residency
requirement
the election was held in the meantime
the
trial court plaintiffs
complained of the two months residency
requirement
this court held the cause of action
moved even though it was denominated as
a class action
there's a big difference
colorado had amended its statute and
texas has not that is correct
but the fact was that you still had if
it is what we want to call it
the the evil still existing are too much
but it was
the other statutes that had been the
subject of the litigation
and that's actually been beneficial
it's not true here it's not what we call
white horse you know i understand
the
in in connection with the with the class
action aspect of this and i
say i have no authority to support this
proposition
but it would appear
that in order for a class action
to continue if there be one to begin
with
is that one plaintiff must remain
or else an intervenor or someone to
be a representative of a class
because this is the whole purpose of the
class action to have a representative in
court
[Applause]
now the possession of the appellate
halton
how do you suggest
if you're right
[Applause]
how to use what what procedure would you
suggest for
any
pregnant female in the state of texas
ever to get any judicial consideration
of this constitutional claim
you want to let me answer
your
question with a statement if i may
[Applause]
i do not believe it can be done
there are
situations in which
of course as a court knows no remedy is
provided i think she makes her choice
prior to the time she becomes pregnant
that is the time of the choice
it's like more or less well the first
three or four years of our life we don't
remember anything
uh but once a child is born a woman no
longer has a choice and i think
pregnancy may terminate that choice as
well maybe she makes a choice when she
decides to live in texas
[Applause]
may i proceed
the
there's no restriction on movies you
know
[Applause]
your honor the appellant hawford is
under
two indictments uh
charged with the or offense of
performing
an abortion
there are no allegations
in in the
complaint of helen hawker or none in his
affidavit that there is any bad faith
uh
prosecution bad faith uh arrest uh
harassment of him at all to bring him
within dombroski's special circumstances
we think the cases of younger versus
harris and samuels versus michael are
controlling as to
dr halford's position
we also feel like that dr hall first
cannot rely upon his patients rights to
to bring him into federal court and i
think the tillerson versus oman case
will will
[Applause]
be authority for that proposition
ask the matter of injunctive relief
after a court once grants declaratory
release
uh i i will make this comment that it
appears the court can consider the
propriety of declaratory relief and can
consider
the propriety of injunctive relief that
is the court can divorce platoon
and once granting declaratory relief
that a statute is unconstitutional
in its discretion can determine whether
or not injunctive relief is proper and
denied if it's fulfilled
now should this court as i understand it
and the the all of the parties feel that
if this court once
acquired jurisdiction of the matter that
the parties would
like the court to
consider all the constitutional issues
uh the
well are you uh are you uh
sustaining uh or
are you saying that the
denial of injunction
was proper because uh
the uh declaratory judgments were there
no your honor i say the court can grant
declaratory relief the
unconstitutionality and deny inductive
really i know but if
certainly
it was erroneous uh it was also right to
deny injunction and injunction
it showed that your position
i think if they if the court
of course uh said he didn't cross appeal
we haven't we could not to this court
your honor we have to go to the fifth
circuit
so we have but are you attempting to
sustain the uh denial of injunction here
on the ground that the declaratory
judgment was in progress
we are
we are asking the court
testing the courts to do this that if
the court
gets into the merits of injunctive
relief whether or not it was proper
under the circumstances that this court
go forward and continue
the other are continued constitutional
issues and make determination
can we do that yeah you're in the fifth
circuit because we said that
you couldn't cross appeal from the
territory judgments you could only cause
fuel and then jump grander denial yeah
uh i i suppose we could do it if we
bypass the total field we'll bring up
for your appeal pending in the fifth
second
couldn't we uh you you're here
your opponent has brought a direct
appeal here because your opponent denied
an injunction by the three judge
district court yes sir you could not
bring it across the field here
because uh
you won from the point of view of
successfully resisting the injunction
yes sir now that you're here as the
apple league
you're arguing that an injunction should
not have issued and part of that
argument
very legitimately can be
that on the merits the court was wrong
and that it shouldn't have issued a
terrorist judgment or an injunction
that's correct
that is your position yes
now the proceedings in the fifth circuit
have been stayed or uh abated
your position makes sense to me
but i know some of our prior
cases rather foreclosure unless we
bypass the
the circuit and bring your appeal
pending there here
well your honor and i don't want to be
your repetition but a motion has been
filed in the fifth circuit to hold the
appeal in abundance until a
determination
you didn't file any motion here asking
us to bring
your appeal pending in the fifth circuit
here for decision
with this appeal did you no we have
requested that in our
in our uh
reply to the jurisdiction and in our
brief
we have presented it in that that manner
you know we feel that this court can or
and should consider all issues and
understand sterling the florida lime and
avocado growers and the carter cases
which are cited in the briefs of the
parties
[Applause]
what is texas interest in this statute
uh
mr justice the
thompson case
which has been cited to the court
thompson versus space
[Applause]
the court of criminal appeals did not
decide the issue of privacy
it was not before the court or the right
of choice issue
the
state
of the state court the court of criminal
appeals held that the state had a
compelling interest
because
of the protection of fetal life
a feat of life protection
they recognize the humanness
of the
uh embryo or the fetus
and they said we have an interest in
protecting a fetal life
whether or not that was the original
intent of the statute
i have no idea and yet the uh yet texas
does not attempt to punish
a woman who herself performs an abortion
on herself
that is correct your honor and the
matter has been brought to my attention
why not punish for murder
since you are destroying
what you
or what has been said to be a human
being
i don't know uh
except that i will say this as medical
science progresses maybe the law will
progress along with it maybe at one time
it could be possible i suppose the
statute could be passed whether or not
that would be constitutional or not well
we're dealing with the statute as it is
there's no there's no state there that
equates abortion with murder or is there
there is none in your honor except one
of our statutes that if the
if the mother dies
that the doctor shall be guilty of
murder but that's ordinary yes fellow
named murderer that's not what space ole
miss yes excuse me texas that's the
covers
[Applause]
uh mr justice best case is just a recent
case you have a citation uh it is it is
not in the reporter system yet are you
going to provide us with a contributor
i'll be happy to yes sir i'll provide
the court with copyright remember you
know
[Applause]
this is number 44070
[Music]
cw thompson
versus
the state of texas
[Applause]
the opinion was delivered on
november the 2nd 1971
i shall be happy to furnish uh the court
with this copy of the court so decide
that's the card of criminal appeal
yeshua
now and that's the case mrs willington
told me depending on
motion for rehearing yesterday
now there's one of them if you leave
that with the clerk
for it we'll
distribute
that in addition uh the thompson case uh
cited a viewed case in regard to
vagueness and said that it's controlling
the issue
and
i as i recall dr thompson raised the
issue of well how can you find me guilty
of murder i mean of abortion
if
you make no determination that the fetus
is alive
at the time
i performed this in effect is what he's
saying he never admitted doing it but
he's saying it
how can you fruit
well of course the texas court answered
by saying it is presumed
the fetus is alive when an abortion is
performed
you say the
in answer to my brother marshall's
question as to what is the interest of
the state in this legislation or even
what is its purpose what is its societal
purpose your answer was i think relying
on your
opinion of the most recent opinion of
the criminal appeals of texas that it
was the protection of fetal life and
then i think you also said that was
perhaps not its original purpose
well i'm not sure of that i it may be
rather important in a constitutional in
a constitutional case of this kind it
becomes
quite vital sometimes to rather
precisely identify
what the asserted interest of the state
is
i think that original purpose mr justice
and the a present prevailing purpose may
be the same in this respect
there have been statistics furnished
to this court
uh in various briefs from various groups
and from uh medical
societies of different uh
groups of physicians and
and
gynecologist or whatever it may be
these statistics are have not shown me
for instance for example
that
abortion is safer than normal childbirth
they have not shown me that they're not
emotional problems
that are very important
uh resulting from
an abortion
uh the protection of the mother
at one time
uh may still be the primary but the the
policy considerations
um that's just would seem likely for the
for the state legislature
to to make a decision originally that's
true policy questions are for
legislative and executive bodies both in
the state and federal government
but
we have here a constitutional question
and
deciding it assessing it it's important
to know what the asserted interest of
the state is and the enactment
of this legislation
i am
and this is just from my i speak
personally i can make i would think that
even when this statue was first
passed there was some concern
for the unborn fetus
when was it enacted it was 1859
was the original statute this i believe
was around 1900 1907 somewhere
back uh close back
in the 19th century yes
before that there were no criminal
abortion laws in texas were there as far
as i know they were not i have no
i think this is maybe set out in some of
the brilliant side
well whenever you don't miss deployed
apart from your personal attitude your
court has spoken on the intent of the
statute yes no yes
well i can't quite square that most
recent pronouncement with the
earlier decisions of the texas court
that refer to the mother as the victim
can you
well
as i say your honor
the i i don't think the courts have come
to the
conclusion that the unborn has full
juristic
rights
not not not yet maybe they will i don't
know i i just don't feel like they have
at the present time first few weeks for
pregnancy
sir in the first few weeks of pregnancy
[Applause]
uh or at any time uh
mr justice we make no distinction
in our state
where there's life there or not
we say there is life from the moment of
impregnation
and do you have any scientific data to
support that
well we begin
mr justice in our brief with the
the development of the human uh embryo
carrying it through to the development
of the fetus from about seven to nine
days after conception
well we're above 60
we don't know but this statute goes all
the way back to one hour i don't uh
miss justice uh
there are unanswerable questions in this
field
[Music]
this is an heartless statement on my
part i withdraw the question thank you
or when does the soul come into the the
unborn if a person believes in a soul i
don't know
[Applause]
i
assume the
[Applause]
appellants now are operating under
the ninth amendment rights there are
allegations of first amendment rights
being violated uh however i feel those
there is no merit this statute does not
establish any religion nor does it
prohibit
anyone from
practicing or being a part of any
religious group
i see no
merit in their contention that it could
possibly be under freedom of speech or
press
in fact there has been some articles
recently in this cities newspaper
yesterday for instance about it
the
other constitutional rights that the
[Music]
appellant speaks of
i think are expressed in two manners
the
individual or marital right of privacy
and secondly or
or the
right to choose whether or not
to abort
a child
now
uh if if if the uh those
are out of the case the the marital
privacy is out of the case
but
be that as it may neither
individual nor marital privacy has been
held to be absolute we have legal search
and seizure
we have the possession of illegal
drugs
[Applause]
the practice of polygamy and other
matters a a parent i do not believe or
perhaps cannot refuse to give their
child some form of education
as far as the freedom over one's body is
concerned
this is not
absolute
the use of illicit drugs
the
indecent exposure legislation
and as mr
uh
mr
goldberg stated in uh in the griswold
case that
uh adultery and fornication
are constitutional beyond doubt
are constitutional or you mean laws
against them
the laws
against
you
[Applause]
now
[Applause]
the there is nothing in the united
states constitution
concerning uh
contraception or abortion
now
the appallee does not disagree with the
appellants
stating that a woman has a choice
but as we have previously mentioned
we feel that this choice is left up is
it is the woman's
prior to the time she becomes
pregnant this is the time of the choice
now this
was brought out in the rosen versus
louisiana state board of medical
examination examiner's case and in party
versus edwards which are lower court
opinions and my understanding is that
that party versus edward
has been adopted in this court
[Applause]
has been yesterday i'm i'm not positive
but i think it has been texas doesn't
grant any exemption in case of
rape the woman their pregnancy has
resulted from rape either statutory or
otherwise
there is nothing in our statute about
that now the procedure such a woman
wouldn't have had a choice would she
uh the uh procedure
and and i'm now i'm telling of course
something is outside the record but i
understand the the procedure when a
woman is brought in an active race if
you try to
stop whatever has occurred immediately
by the proper procedure in a
in the um the hospital
immediately she's taken there and she
reports it immediately but no there is
nothing
[Applause]
now as i previously informed the court
the statistics
are the people who prepare the
statistics and the different
uh statistics or
or not in
conformity in connection with the
medical aspects
of abortion that is whether or not it's
safer
there are some statistics that will say
it is
statistics that say it's not uh there
have it has been provided to this court
the common law and the legislative
history of abortion
and that the
uh the morality of abortion has been
injected in various uh
cases and
by various groups
now we think these matters the matters
of policy should be properly addressed
by the state legislature
we think that the consideration should
be given
to the unborn
and in some instances a consideration
should be given to the father
if he would be objective to abortion
thank you your honor
your time is consumed unless you have
some correction you wish to make this is
written i would only like to draw to the
court's attention at page 130 of the
record the notice of appeal by defendant
state of texas from the judgment of the
district court to the supreme court of
the united states they have filed an
appeal in this court
thank you mrs weddington thank you
mr floyd the case is submitted
in a seven to two decision the court
held that a woman's right to an abortion
fell within the right to privacy
protected by the 14th amendment the
ruling gave a woman total autonomy over
her pregnancy during the first trimester
affecting the abortion laws of 46 states
the court issued its ruling on january
22nd 1973.
you can read the roe vs wade opinion
written by justice harry blackman at
cspan.org
by clicking on america and the courts
join us next week for america and the
courts saturday evenings at 7 eastern on
c-span
tonight on american